hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to slow varial now I
should be playing with fans in this one
I shared out this party seed on Twitter
and hopefully when this is done doing
the loading weird thing I don't even
know what that's about but hopefully
there's gonna be less lag but either way
there we go now I'm actually in a game
hopefully I'm gonna be in the can with
everybody else No
is that not how this works oh boy I
really really really hope that I'm in
the same level as everyone else because
otherwise I'm gonna be playing by myself
and everything is gonna be lonely
forever and ever and also where's the
goddamn dots oh I'm going towards the
outskirts I need to go in we need to go
deeper I mean this must be a relatively
new server the people on the lever to
board seem to actually be kind of small
kinda teensy tiny I have a funny feeling
that a lot of people are probably trying
to do if anything like agario is what's
gonna happen here they're not gonna
trust me when it comes to me being me
they're gonna fudge me over so good not
good not in a good way don't take that
out of context no you don't Oh who's
gonna die oh that guy apparently that
guy wasn't even trying to die he was
just trying to be peaceful off on his
own but look at what happened missed me
dickbag somehow I'm number 17 on the
server hooray
probably just everybody trying to kill
me is what's happening sorry I'll let
you go you get you can go you're not
worth you're not worth in trapping all
the party is over here all that poor guy
oh that poor guy I guess we're getting
into the party now things are starting
to move up in the world and that often
doesn't mean a lot of good for me but
got that one
okay good good good what are you doing
get out here
everyone's trying for me everyone's
gunning for me oooh people wand me bad
people want to eat me up I'm going
towards the outskirts I need to circle
back and go back in because I'm not
gonna allow myself to be deceived
defeated my apparently is weird my giant
pink snake is gonna be your going into
the center eating a lot of balls Oh
how'd this guy die doesn't matter give
me gimme oh so good for me don't even
know how this guy died you just died and
there's no one to pick up the pieces
kind of just he just gave up and then
logged off and then everyone was just
left to pick up the pieces
well I'm number eight on the leaderboard
so that's pretty good shows my
incredible skill how did I miss these
things well hey buddy how you doing how
you doing buddy okay alrighty then I
have a funny feeling that people are
trying to entrap me here it's probably
true this seems like people are gunning
for me when in reality they shouldn't
because they're not gonna be good enough
what are you gonna do yeah you better
back off yeah people are just like in a
holding pattern it's so weird
Todd there's so many people there's so
many people oh so close on that guy
really oh hello alright then well I got
this guy eventually he's mine in some
regard I wonder how much how long can we
play this game of cat and mouse there we
go
cat and mouse over time for me to nom
yay yum yum ah damn it there's some down
in there I'm gonna get him oh jeez okay
I'm number 5 still entirely possible for
me to royally this up I'm number 4
oh if I get to number 3 I'll be even
better oh boy well that guy dad give me
that I don't know if that was
intentional but I'll take it
oh come on Oh number 3 whoa whoa done it
I've accomplished everything I can die
happy now I can if I die
it's gonna be totally okay I'll be not
angry at all about it I'll be totally
chill and relaxed and totes cool breath
it's gonna be cool totally cool
boys dangerous those dangerous for me to
do whoa how's dangerous whoa I took my I
took my snake on a journey there and it
wasn't a good one well ah you
whoa almost got you yeah okay so number
three man number two is far off from me
wow that is like you that's more than
double my score how am I gonna catch up
to that I don't even know what the the
glowing moving ones do if they're
actually any more beneficial than any
other they may be they may not be boy
I'm number two Oh
God number one probably bit the dust or
number two bit the dust
well I'm number two baby whoa whoa I'm
number two you want to play
whoa how'd that guy die who cares that
was like I was like narrowly avoided
derailment woohoo
that was too close I hugged that guy a
little too close see the big guy Gaiden
first-place tragedy
he's just encircling everybody he
doesn't give a he'll play he'll
play the waiting game and goddamn he is
good at it I don't know if I'm ever
gonna get to that point but I got what I
got and what I got is my big pink snake
and my big picks neck is gonna do a lot
of damage darker placard Dargan blare
over there hey Durga Blair you want to
give me you Marquis boos here you know
it's good for you I need to get back
towards the center because I'm missing
out on a lot of the action I'm still
number two there was a guy in second
place above me for like one second then
I'm I'm just assuming that this marks
Magnum dong I drop my Magnum condom from
my Magnum dong
sorry I'm immature
almost got me there whoa
how's dangerous good thing that guy
didn't do anything about it good him go
team go team go team go Tim go Tim
Brooke ten thousand here yay yeah oh god
oh god oh god oh my god that was not
cool wolf you barely escaped buddy you
barely escaped escaped the wrath of the
markimoo none can escape forever you can
try but I will always catch up
eventually Marky boot coming through the
MARC train is rolling
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate I've got a whole bunch of
people here gonna do me any good people
just give up and smack into my walls
they smack into my giant pink snake oh
boy you want to be part of the party oh
you you just help me release them so oh
hello sceptre flyer are you going there
with your your Magnum doing oh gosh this
is stressful I wonder if I can gobble up
cept applier that would be that would be
a thing haha oh God Oh at least you died
oh okay
god damn it damn it I was number two
I'll never be able to beat that man I
couldn't have gotten the number one
number one was gonna be impossible but
man goddamn it oh well so thank you
everybody so much huh oh thank you
everybody so much for watching it this
has been split varial if you want to see
more of this and agario check the linked
in the description below play this game
for yourself
it's super duper fun thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you
in the next video